Film Courage: When you look at a script whether you
plan to produce or direct it,
how are you analyzing it to see if this
is a project you want to be a part of?
Joey Travolta, Filmmaker: Well with Carol The Bells movie
most of it I mean I've developed a lot
of the scripts that we did end up making
because I had development deals with
several studios but they never got made
that's why it went independent with them
putting them together and some of them
have certain elements that's do it and
maybe some cash or whatever but like for
Carol of the bells
I was in Bentonville at the Bentonville
Film Festival [Arkansas]l and we always make short
films at the studios so up until the
time that I was I I was doing like two
features a year and then when I started
doing the programs I did a couple of
documentaries but I hadn't done a
feature in a while but at the workshops
throughout California we teach camera we
teach lighting set building anything
that goes into filmmaking we teach we
develop a short film and that film
becomes a lesson plan for that semester
so we're constantly making content so I
looked at the overall picture we have
six studios that have pros working there
and all these students that we've
trained I said why don't we do a feature
it's time to do a feature and at the
film festival I had run into a woman
named Gail Williamson who is an agent
for folks that are neuro-diverse and we
were on the same panel and I said hey I
said you you have any scripts I'm
looking for something that features
somebody with a disability that's simple
to do small cast simple locations and
that's when I read carol of the bells
and it met that criteria I'm looking to
do you know because like in Bakersfield
the community works with us
so locations you can get for free
they just opened their doors to you
there so you're getting really good
production value we made a great deal
with the hotels and the the the way we
did it was each facility like
Bakersfield has mine I own and the other
ones are like franchises so they sent
two pros down and two students and then
we used all our students that were ready
to work to make this and so the criteria
for that was limited locations getting
as much production value as you can with
no money and again its borrowing
stealing whatever but it's going in and
you know going in to someone's house and
saying hey you know we'd love to shoot
here we don't have any money would you
let us use your house and finding some
beautiful locations and people working
with you so it's a good way to learn
filmmaking you know to do without when
you produce something because then later
when you have money it's like oh I
remember the first time a direct that a
union issue
it was Honey I Shrunk The Kids movie and all
of a sudden they had a staff of like 75
people in a production meeting and we're
talking about okay we'll do this and
we'll do that it was when I just joined
the DGA
I had to because I was directing an
episode John Landis was producing the
show at the time he was a friend of mine
and so we're at the meeting and and
we're talking about we were talking
about there was a scene where they were
putting a dog on trial and I said okay I
said you know would be really cool is
when that dog is sworn in if he had a
jury of his peers and have all dogs and
they said we love that okay great like
that so we got all dogs and it was
really cute scene and then they were
talking about you know they'd like to
get someone this special outfit for it
and I was like well you know I said
there's a mall right over by my hotel I
can go and get that you know after and
they said you don't need to do that you
know you don't need you don't need to do
anything we have people that do all that
because you can't add on a set you can't
touch anything when it's a union issue
if you're the light lighting people
touch the lighting crip touch grip you
know and I'm used to like you know
really being involved and we needed to
move a light you move the light you know
so it was it was a little tough getting
used to having that many people working
with you but I did get my jury of the
peers and it was really very cute when
you looked at scripts previously to
carol of the bells what were you looking
for I mean it is it something that a lot
of them are created
you know we developed ourselves so we
were just looking for good stories
either about when we create well if not
I was involved with the creation like
the movie male Navajo blues detour these
are all scripts that we were da Vinci's
were these are all scripts that we
developed in-house so you just look for
a really good story and I have a couple
of scripts I want to eventually do but
you know I'm a little busy right now so
it's I spend all my time at you know
doing camps and traveling around but I
want to do one more and I don't know
what that's going to be yet so knowing
that you were a teacher I don't know if
you had your teaching credential or
okay when do you think an artist should
leave their day job
suppose an artist has something well
they leave that that when they can
afford to you know when they can afford
to do it I guess I don't know I never
really had a day job I don't think I
ever had it
well the tire shop if you consider that
where was this and new Travolta Tire
Exchange in New Jersey oh that was not I
was changing tires up until I had a
record on the chart
I got a call and and it was Jimmy Einar
and the guy said hey your record is like
50 with a bullet and I was like well
tell him I'll call him back I gotta
finish balance so and so you're working
on that car what's going through your
head at that moment oh it was pretty
exciting you know to have a charting
record that's what you that's what you
hope for when you were an artist but I
was still working at the tire shops oh
and when did you finally say listen I
don't think I'll be putting in as many
hours here uh when I moved out to
California I I was still I mean I was
still putting it to help out my dad and
stuff like that so he's dry excuse me
sorry did you drive out did you drive no
no no we flew out and I remember we
would I was stopping in at a development
there with paramount we stopped in Vegas
to do the Jerry Lewis telethon and then
we move right there and then I started
Sunnyside shortly after that what was
your first apartment in it was in
Westwood and we got robbed so we moved
to Beverly Hills and we got robbed again
so we moved further into Beverly Hills
yeah it was I crazy
it was quite we got robbed like twice it
was there like a rash of like burglaries
or what would really not just that you
know they won they broke through the
window the other oh my god they my
father-in-law who is a comedian Dick
Shawn and he was in movies like the
producers and it's a mad mad world and
he used to get us gifts and it was just
when those duffle bags came
they were becoming popular and on this
trip he gave us three huge duffel bags
that were stuffed with Chinese newspaper
and he says you gotta go this is
unbelievable because again you do a lot
of traveling you're gonna need this
he goes you would be surprised what you
can get in these bags so the next day I
got a Wendy and I just got married and I
think was at the racetrack or something
I got a call and they said Mrs.Travolta
you you know your wife just called your
house was robbed and I'm going oh man so
this is Beverly Hills now they literally
took the front door in midday off the
hinges and we had a goal that we still
have golden retrievers we had a golden
retriever that was sitting in the middle
of the living room with Chinese
newspapers all around him they used the
duffel bags to rob us so when he said
you'd be surprised what you can get in
these bags they took everything but if
they had gone another room over my
wife's diamond ring was in there and
cash and a camera and all that but the
golden retriever was just pointing out
the most expensive things and and so and
then we we move further into Beverly
Hills but they left the dog alone the
dog was just said it was like I said he
was probably pointed to things now yeah
that over there so did you want to go
back to New Jersey
you